there's a reason why Javon Davis is the
favorite out of the two again Ryan's the
only one that's been knocked down yeah
knocked down that Luke Campbell fight
right which he went on to win but so we
see that Ryan has a good chin we don't
know about Javonte Davis's chin and
it will get tested in this fight Ryan's
too quick he's gonna land stuff and in
order for tank to win this fight he has
to walk through some and that is
the quickness and speed of Ryan Garcia
which could leave him open so we're
gonna find out is tank right now as you
pound for pound best right now what's he
like when he gets hit if he does get
knocked down how does he recover this
fight ain't going to decision if it goes
decision I think Ryan wins I think Ryan
wins and he can't give up rounds early
either he got to win those early rounds
you got to put that money in the bank
early on out maneuver him use your
quickness there's a way for Ryan to win
not gonna be easy we need tank to step
out of pocket and make some mistakes and
you need Ryan to land with his speed and
quickness and even so if that does land
the question is is that enough to get
tanked out of there we haven't really
seen tank get hit